Oh oh yes yes
wow that's what I'm talking about right
here this is why I don't leave when
people do drugs
now I'm at a house party and this guy's
got an alligator on his face
[Music]
very very funny comic glad to have them
here you guys know him as a host of the
crap B's podcast give it up for mr. Ryan
Sickler everybody you guys like drugs
alright I don't really do drugs alright
I smoke a little weed I drink a beer now
and then I've never done cocaine I've
never done acid I'm not in the pills
like the hard stuff scares me alright
but in the right situation I love to be
around people on drugs anything is
possible when someone's on drugs
alright like right now if you said hey
do you mind if I smoke some heroin while
you tell this story
I'd say fire that up let's see
where the night takes you so I'm
originally from Baltimore and grew up
out in Sykesville Maryland and when I
graduated high school I played soccer
for junior college aka Community College
aka the 13th grade and so when you play
sports with guys in high school you play
all four years you know and well you're
in school with them you everybody knows
each other when I got to college not
everyone knew each other and the dude on
the team said hey man a friend of mine
is having a party tonight down at Fort
McHenry we should all go get to know one
another and hang out now quick history
lesson for you here if you don't know
Fort McHenry is where Francis Scott Key
wrote our national anthem all right
he wrote the star-spangled banner there
I'm going to a house party there we all
have our paths
so I get to the door to knock on the
door and his big dude answers and when I
say big I don't want to be misleading he
wasn't built like the rock but he was
more like sloth from Goonies okay
sizeable dude was sizable and he says
welcome to my party my name is Sparks I
said well thank you for having me Sparks
I go in I'm hanging out with the guys on
the team we're drinking and smoking
sparks is right there drinking and
smoking with us then he disappears
downstairs a few minutes later he comes
back up drinking and smoking disappears
downstairs again now I don't know what's
going on down there I can hear some
voices I only assume it's like buddies
of his local guys they've been there a
while they're not mixing with us or not
mixing with them but Sparks is going
back and forth about the fifth time
Sparks comes up the stairs
he's got cocaine all over his face and
I'm just like oh I got it
you're up here drinking and smoking with
us you're down there doing cocaine with
them you're being a great host so I
don't know if you've ever hung out with
someone that's done way too much cocaine
at one time but Sparks has these big
eyes and this smile plastered on his
face ear to ear and he's bouncing like
this in front of us in the living room
like I am in front of you all right now
and he keeps snapping his neck and
looking to the rear corner of the living
room he's like and then he walks back
there and in the corner there's a little
aquarium with a blanket on it and he
rips the blanket off all right now we're
in a row home all right it's narrow but
it's deep so from where I'm sitting at
first I'm like man that kind of looks
like an alligator you know what it
actually was a alligator
yeah sparks has a pet alligator and it's
sitting in this aquarium on on some
rocks and like half-full of water you
know natural alligator habitat and spark
steps right up next to it and without
taking his eyes off of us he lays his
arm in the tank and he starts swaying
back and forth in the water alongside
the alligators body I'm like here we go
here we go here it is back and forth
cocaine okay back and forth back and
forth then he picks the alligator up now
there's a dinosaur at the party two
dudes on the team leave guy sitting next
to me is like hey I think we should get
the hell out of here too and I was like
what are you talking about this just got
good like do I need to remind you right
now that you're at a party with
marijuana alcohol cocaine and an
alligator in a historic neighborhood
where else do you want to be in the
country tonight man this is the spot we
got a front row seat and sparks is
holding this thing by the belly okay and
it's big all right now it's not Gator
world big we weren't gonna like sit on
its back and take pictures but it's like
the size of a big cat I'd say from the
snout to the base of the tail it's about
this big and then the tail hangs down
and he's holding it with both hands by
the belly with the snout right at his
face like I have this microphone right
now and guns and roses was big at the
time I say that cuz sparks busted out
his best Axl Rose and starts dancing
with this alligator
cocaine cocaine and then he kisses it on
the mouth and I'm like this is what I'm
talking about this is what I'm talking
about right here and he kisses it again
and you know that little shady side I
the alligators have that little eye they
have that alligators looking out at all
of us like is this series
and then he kissed at a third time and
that alligator said snap and I was like
oh oh yes yes just what I'm talking
about right here this is why I don't
leave when people do drugs now I'm at a
house party and this guy's got an
alligator on his face do you know how
pissed off I would have been if I left
and someone called me the next day and
said you're not gonna believe what
happened oh I've been devastated but I
didn't leave I stayed right there and
this alligator is clamped down on spars
his face in his eyes there's still big
completely different emotion in there
now starting to see the panic settle in
but I'll never forget the look in that
alligators eyes cuz that's that was his
first time tasting flesh blood and
cocaine that's like a reptile Mega
Millions right there and it's on it's on
tight it's not going anywhere and I'll
say this too for people from Baltimore
some of the toughest people I've ever
met in my life
all right this Gator is locked and he's
not screaming and if he is I can't hear
it over my laughter and sparks don't
know what to do you know I'm not getting
up in help and I'm not putting my hand
in an alligator's mouth I just opened
another beer and he knows there's no one
coming to his rescue
and he does what he has to do and he
rips it off of his face yeah and he goes
over he sets it back down in the
aquarium he's got his hand over his face
like this he takes it off
cocaine's gone at this point
and he goes I'm not bleeding and he
wasn't and then he put his hand over his
face again and he took it off when I was
like now you are a lot man your face
isn't supposed to do that man
maybe the cocaine acted as a coagulant
for a second but you're gushing right
now man and sparks said I'm calling the
cops I was like the cop for what
alligator assault what the hell you
calling the cops for man like let me
remind you man you've got marijuana
cocaine and alcohol here with underage
kids and you just took a gator to the
face man the cops are going to come in
here and beat the hell out of us you
need medical attention call 9-1-1 they
don't care about this kind of stuff he
said no I'm calling the cops I said well
I'm not going to be here when they get
here and I think Sparks for having me
hit him with a see you later alligator
got that hell out of Fort McKenna
I'm Ryan Sickler thank you
[Music]